the jurgen experience and so then the
state becomes your daddy and then the
state decides that you know like in the
case of north korea that it's its daddy
is super powerful and plays golf better
than anybody that's ever lived you read
the account of kim jong-un playing golf
no but i know like him and dennis
rodriguez
i read something about it that it might
be just a misinterpretation that got way
blown out of proportion it sounds like
jaime works for the state no there's a
way to there's a way to keep score where
you're not writing down the actual
number you got you're just writing down
relative to par he had 11 holes in one
but that's not how that's just someone
read the score wrong and it got reported
that way is how i read this
interpretation but that was the
interpretation of the glowing um media
coverage in the north korean news wasn't
it i i'd read through this in like a
golf magazine
you know expose golf magazine's getting
paid
it just made more sense when it was
written that way as all he got to score
way more accurately that he should have
like 120 or something like that
i don't know what that means uh since i
don't play golf but
his his holes in one would have been one
over rather than an actual one
that's how they were writing the score
down that's all i'm trying to say
so what was that the depiction that we
read so then the someone saw that
scorecard was like holy [ __ ] what they
don't understand there's different golf
but that wasn't written by the north
korean news i'm just i'll pull up the
article i read i'm just sort of telling
you it seems like i'm going out of
reports i wanted to do a sketch called
like north korean sports center and it's
just kim jong-un like beating he's like
winning the finals in the world cup and
like he's just this man he's elbow
dunking on on like lebron
like great leader wins again yeah
i had yomi park
on the podcast a woman who escaped north
korea yeah you want to talk about a lady
who just doesn't want to hear any
[ __ ] when you escape north korea and
you make it into china as a sex slave
when you're 13 you have no tolerance for
[ __ ]
none
no tolerance for [ __ ]
just what the [ __ ] man the fact that
that is going on right now and that in
2022 while you and i are sitting here
drinking whiskey and talking [ __ ]
there's people that are slaves
in korea and in north korea and they
can't get out yeah they're trapped and
they're barely alive they barely survive
in terms of like their ability to just
have enough food to live
and they live in concentration camps and
they
they work for the state you live in
slave camps and you might even not have
ever done anything you might be born in
that slave camp like she was explaining
like how like if one generation like say
if your grandfather does something
that's bad against the state
they will curse multiple generations so
you will you'll be imprisoned and your
children be in prison and their children
be imprisoned before their children get
released
that's [ __ ] you're on the hook for a
previous generation what the [ __ ] man
yeah you you'll live the rest of your
life in jail because your grandfather
was an [ __ ] you're not even born yet
and you're already [ __ ] what did you
pull up jamie uh so this reporter went
to the golf course where this happened
and he explains in here how it went from
an innocent score keeping mistake and
got
before i tell you what i know i should
tell you how i came to know it the
details were relayed to me five years
ago during my own travels in north korea
where i turned turned up to compete in a
tournament billed as the national
championship the north korean open is
more curiosity than cutthroat contest
which is only fitting given that it's
held in pyongyang golf course the same
layout where the deer leader allegedly
shot his 34 the fields in the annual
handicapped event are fairly small most
of golfers struggle to break 90. so it
goes on and explains how he talked to
some people there
he they taught they explained to him
that there was a score keeping shorthand
that is used there and then someone
whoever found that in the north korean
state news
most likely didn't know that
and then ran with uh
okay so it says unfamiliar with the
score keeping shorthand the north korean
state news agency covering the outing
had read the five ones on kim's card as
holes in one forget the fact that kim a
rank beginner probably never sniffed
bogey all day if you were keeping score
for a brutal autocrat would you dare
tell him he'd made nothing but snowmen i
don't know what you [ __ ] dorks
talking on your lips
shut your mouth
his alleged aces okay
maybe that's all so i would like to uh
pretend that i didn't read that all
right just go with the original
propaganda piece because i think it was
awesome that they said he scored 15
holes in one
or whatever he's not a golf guy no i
would be a golf guy though i would
definitely look at tony hinchcliffe and
jamie and ron white play it'd be fun to
play with him i think what i'm going to
do one day is uh when jamie and tony
finally play i'm going to film it on the
iphone
and just get super baked and just talk
[ __ ] to them what if you remember
you're like happy gilmore no i'm not
gonna play no you gotta play no if i
played with them i would hold them back
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing